Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的内容之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“追求经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. episode. With Dr. Marianne Trent Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast.
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa亲自提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。如果你正寻求成为一名心理学家，那么让这期节目成为你的指南。我是Marianne Trent博士，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》。
I, as you might know by now, even if just from the jingles, I am Dr. Marianne Trent. And I am here to make this whole process a little bit more like it feels like it's on your side. And hopefully like you have some control and some compassion, someone that gets it, someone that gets why this is important to you. And I would hope that I am not the only person in your life who does see you, who does see why this is important to you and supports you with it. But I know that we sometimes can be very different than the families where we were raised. We can be different than those we are around. And that can make us feel a bit more lonely, actually, a little bit less supported than would be ideal. Or maybe those who are around you, just, you know, they try their best, but they don't really get it. I was speaking to my personal trainer yesterday and she was a midwife originally and we were talking a bit of a personal professional reflection
正如你现在可能已经知道的那样，哪怕只是从片头曲里听到的，我就是Marianne Trent博士。我在这里是为了让整个过程让你感觉更贴心，让你感到更有掌控感和同理心，让你觉得有人理解你，有人明白为什么这对你如此重要。我希望我不是你生命中唯一一个能看到你、理解你为何重视这一切并支持你的人。但我知道，我们有时可能与抚养我们长大的家庭非常不同，与周围的人也不同。这实际上会让我们感到更孤独，得到的支持比理想中要少。又或者，你身边的人虽然尽力了，但他们并不真正理解。昨天我和我的私人教练聊天，她原本是一名助产士，我们进行了一些个人和职业层面的反思，
as I was strength training but we were talking about what it's like working in a service where you're caring for others and when you are surrounded by people who don't work in that same kind of zone, that same realm and how hard it can be for people who might be working in very different environments, who might have very different job roles to really grasp what it is that we are doing. So this episode of the podcast is kind of, yeah, it's for the people around you, but it's also for you to use this, hopefully, as a bit of a reflective space to think about what it is that you need optimally and whether, you know, when we're on model for thinking about complex trauma, which is my specialty, whether we're thinking now that we're grown, whether we can perhaps do some of the things that would help us to feel optimally supported, but do them for ourselves rather than waiting
当时我正在进行力量训练。我们谈到了在服务行业照顾他人是什么感觉，以及当你被那些不在同一领域工作的人包围时，对于那些在完全不同环境、担任完全不同职位的人来说，要真正理解我们在做什么有多么困难。所以这期播客，既是为你身边的人准备的，也是为你准备的，希望你能把它当作一个反思空间，思考你最需要什么。当我们运用复杂创伤（这是我的专长）的思维模型时，思考我们成年后是否可以做一些事情来帮助自己获得最佳支持，而不是等待
for someone to come and rescue us, which may or may not happen. So you might be listening to this because you do love and care for someone who is an aspiring psychologist and they thought it might be helpful for you to listen to. I know that someone recently contacted me to say that her partner already listens to this, not because he has any interest in psychology, but because he likes my voice. And she did do a bit of a funny emoji then so um thank you to you whoever you are that is listening and if you are the partner concerned she might well be jabbing you in the ribs now and saying yeah that's you that's you um so let's um also you know compared to the previous episode that I filmed, which was how to be a psychologist when you're not in the mood. Please note that my audio is hopefully sounding a whole heap better. Because today, dear listeners, I can be bothered. And actually, I've had more comments about the I can't be bothered.
别人来拯救我们，因为这可能发生，也可能不会。所以你可能正在听这期节目，因为你爱护着一位有抱负的心理学家，而他们认为让你听听这期节目可能会有帮助。我知道最近有人联系我说，她的伴侣已经在听这个播客了，不是因为他对心理学感兴趣，而是因为他喜欢我的声音。当时她还发了一个有趣的表情符号。所以，无论你是谁，感谢你的收听。如果你就是那位伴侣，她现在可能正在戳你的肋骨说：“没错，就是你，就是你。”那么，让我们……还有，与我录制的上一期节目《当你没心情时如何成为一名心理学家》相比，请注意，我的音频听起来应该好多了。因为今天，亲爱的听众们，我有心情录制了。事实上，关于“我没心情”的那期节目，我收到的评论比我目前发布的任何其他节目都要多。
I'm not in the mood. And that combined with the comments regarding the brilliant episode that I did with Lucy Johnston than any of the other episodes that I have released so far. It really resonated with people. Well, obviously, Lucy Johnson's did. She's incredible. That's a really strong episode to listen to on formulation and the power threat meaning framework. If you haven't caught that already, then please do. That is episode number 21. But episode number 22 was, yeah, how to be a psychologist when you're not in the mood. And that really has resonated with people.
它真的引起了人们的共鸣。当然，Lucy Johnston的那期节目也引起了共鸣，她太棒了。那是一期非常值得一听的关于“构思”（formulation）和“权力威胁意义框架”（Power Threat Meaning Framework）的节目。如果你还没听过，请一定要去听，那是第21期。但第22期《当你没心情时如何成为一名心理学家》确实引起了人们的强烈共鸣。
It's really helped them feel seen, you know, and heard, which is a very nice position to be in, that people do go out of their way to say god i loved that that was really good um and someone else has been in contact with me about the psychiatry episode they really found that useful and you know really opened their eyes to thinking about um whether you know how important um the history of mental health is so yeah if you particularly enjoyed one of the episodes or maybe all of the episodes and you're like touting to be my biggest fan maybe you're like my children and you think I should also have merch I don't see it coming anytime soon but you know if you would indeed buy merch let me know let me know my children will be
它真的帮助他们感到被看见、被听见，这是一种非常好的感觉。人们特意跑来告诉我：“天哪，我太喜欢那一期了，真的很好。”还有人联系我谈论关于精神病学的节目，他们觉得非常有用，这确实让他们大开眼界，开始思考心理健康史有多么重要。所以，如果你特别喜欢其中某一期，或者所有节目，并且你觉得自己是我最大的粉丝，也许你像我的孩子们一样，认为我也应该有周边产品——虽然我还没看到这一天，但如果你真的会买周边，请告诉我。我的孩子们会
delighted I feel like because I've mentioned my children I do now need to say what they say to me all the time which is mummy do ask them to subscribe to you on LinkedIn do ask them to like do ask them to comment so if you're on um did I just say LinkedIn? I'm like LinkedIn obsessed. Come and engage with me on LinkedIn by all means. But I was talking about YouTube. So yeah, come along on YouTube. At the moment, you won't be able to actually see my lovely face because I'm wearing a green top that actually I have spilt a bit of toothpaste on, I won't lie. And so I am not camera ready, but you can still stream this content via YouTube. So, yeah, if you're over on YouTube or if you're like multitasking, as we are pretty good at doing in psychology, then just, you know, flick across to good thinking psychological services on youtube and just flick across to good thinking psychological services on youtube and come and like everything comment engage do all those wonderful things you could even click the notification bell couldn't you whilst you're there go on my children are going to throw me a party
很高兴的。我觉得既然提到了我的孩子们，我就必须说出他们一直对我念叨的话：“妈妈，一定要让他们在LinkedIn上关注你，一定要让他们点赞，一定要让他们评论。”所以，如果你在……我刚才是不是说了LinkedIn？我简直是LinkedIn狂热粉。无论如何，欢迎在LinkedIn上与我互动。但我刚才想说的是YouTube。所以，欢迎来到YouTube。目前，你可能看不到我可爱的脸，因为我穿了一件绿色的上衣，上面不小心溅到了一点牙膏，我不会撒谎。所以我还没准备好出镜，但你仍然可以通过YouTube收听这些内容。所以，如果你在YouTube上，或者像我们心理学人一样擅长多任务处理，那就切换到YouTube上的“Good Thinking Psychological Services”，去点赞、评论、互动，做所有那些美妙的事情。你甚至可以在那里点击通知小铃铛，对吧？去吧，我的孩子们会为我举办派对的，
when i get to 200 subscribers so come on help make that happen you can do it you've got the power anyway I digress as I tend to do at times because it's hard talking to yourself when you're just looking at a podcast mic I find that I go to various wonderful places anyway so So you are perhaps listening to this episode because you're either an aspiring psychologist yourself or because you love and care about someone who is. And, you know, sometimes people tell me that people go, oh, well, you know, why would you do this if you don't have to, you know, given that it's so competitive to get places or, you know, if you're going into counselling psychology, given that you
当我达到200个订阅者时，所以来吧，帮我实现这个目标，你可以做到的，你有这个力量。总之，我跑题了，我有时就是这样，因为当你对着播客麦克风自言自语时，很难不走神。总之，你可能正在听这期节目，要么是因为你自己就是一位有抱负的心理学家，要么是因为你爱护着这样一个人。你知道，有时人们会问我：“如果不是非做不可，为什么要这么做呢？考虑到进入这个行业竞争如此激烈，或者如果你要进入咨询心理学领域，考虑到你
have to self fund and there's many, many, many hoops to jump through for things like forensic, why would you bother? You know, why don't you just go and get yourself, you know, a better paid job? You know, you know, the people that you were at university with, you know, they don't you just go and get yourself, you know, a better paid job? You know, you know, the people that you were at university with, you know, they're now earning X amount, you know, they're not having to study every weekend, you know, looks like they're having a great time on Facebook or Instagram because you're probably younger and cooler than me. But yeah, and it's like, oh, I don't really, I don't feel that seen or I don't feel that heard because let me tell you how it was for me. It felt and it feels like this profession is part of me. You know, it was always going to come to fruition. That's how it felt to me.
必须自费，而且像法医心理学这样的领域有无数的障碍要跨越，你为什么要自找麻烦呢？为什么不去找一份薪水更高的工作呢？你大学时的那些同学，他们现在赚多少钱啊，他们不用每个周末都在学习，看起来他们在Facebook或Instagram上过得很开心，因为你可能比我年轻、比我酷。”这让我感觉不太被看见或听见，因为让我告诉你我的感受。我觉得这个职业是我的一部分。你知道，它注定会实现。这就是我的感觉。
Once I decided what I wanted to do, I felt just that, you know, so my husband was really surprised when we met. He was like, why haven't you got more hobbies? Like, what do you do? And I'm like, well, you know, I do a bit of Pilates and I sing in the shower. You know, I like hanging out with my friends. He's like, yeah, but you don't do anything. I was like, well, I don't know. I'm all right with that. I'm all right with that. And I, you know, on reflection, think it's because I so enjoy my job that I haven't been looking for like distractions or reasons to get up each day, you know, and counting down the hours when I'm at work. Because generally, as I said in the I Can't Be Bothered podcast episode, generally, I love what I do. And it feels like a real honour that I get to do it. And for someone who doesn't feel that way about their work, you know, perhaps they're living for the weekends rather than living
一旦我决定了我想做什么，我就感觉到了。所以当我丈夫和我见面时，他真的很惊讶。他说：“你为什么没有更多的爱好？你平时都做什么？”我说：“嗯，我做点普拉提，在淋浴时唱歌，喜欢和朋友们出去玩。”他说：“是啊，但你什么正事都不做。”我说：“嗯，我不知道，我觉得这样挺好的。”回想起来，我想是因为我太热爱我的工作了，以至于我没有去寻找消遣或每天起床的理由，也不用在工作时倒计时。因为总的来说，正如我在《我没心情》那期播客中所说，我热爱我的工作。这感觉真是一种荣幸。而对于那些对工作没有这种感觉的人来说，也许他们是为了周末而活，而不是为了
to work. And I wouldn't say I'm living to work, but it feels like I get to bring myself to work. I do probably laugh a bit less when I'm at work, although my clients are very funny sometimes as well. So that's not always true. But, you know, it's yeah, it's not a hardship doing my job. And it feels well, it is sometimes it is sometimes, you know, when we're working with incredibly complex clients that just, you know, it makes you feel sad for what they have been through that's one of the hardest parts of my job is to just think how mean and awful people can be um to one another and also to themselves too um and that's part of you know my thinking around compassion focused therapy as well is we have to be able to embrace how awful humans can be to ourselves and to others as well is we have to be able to embrace how awful humans can be to ourselves and to others as well
工作而活。我不会说我是为了工作而活，但我觉得我能把真实的自己带到工作中。虽然我在工作时笑得可能少一点，尽管我的客户有时也非常幽默，所以这也不总是真的。但做我的工作并不辛苦。虽然有时确实很辛苦，当你与极其复杂的客户一起工作时，这让你为他们所经历的一切感到难过。这是我工作中比较困难的部分之一，去思考人们对彼此，以及对自己，可以有多么刻薄和糟糕。这也是我关于“同情心聚焦疗法”（Compassion Focused Therapy）思考的一部分，我们必须能够拥抱人类对自己和他人可以有多么糟糕的事实。
but yeah how if you are listening to this can you support an aspiring psychologist without invalidating them even accidentally you know by suggesting they can do something else. So sometimes that might be useful. So I know when I was an aspiring psychologist myself, I was applying to jobs all over the country. You know, at one point I had an interview offered to me in the Lake District and one in Nottingham. And I was living close to Milton Keynes and working there currently. And I was also doing a distance learning master's, which was based in Birmingham. And that's a lot. You know, I was also recovering from a car crash and I'd broken up with my partner. That's a lot to be going through.
但如果你正在听这期节目，你该如何支持一位有抱负的心理学家，而不让他们感到被否定，哪怕是无意的？比如建议他们去做别的事情。有时这可能是有用的。我知道当我还是一个有抱负的心理学家时，我正在全国各地申请工作。有一次，我同时收到了湖区和诺丁汉的面试邀请。当时我住在米尔顿凯恩斯附近，并在那里工作。我还在攻读一个位于伯明翰的远程硕士学位。这压力太大了。我当时还在从车祸中恢复，而且刚和伴侣分手。要经历这些真的很难。
And then to suddenly be having to dart around to different interviews. I also had one at an interview in Birmingham at the same time, I seem to recall as well. And I just felt like one day I just thought, oh, I can't do all of this. You know, it feels it feels too much. You know, I'd hit a bit of a wall and I just thought what am I doing and I almost needed permission from my mum to say why don't you you know cancel the Lake District interview because maybe upon reflection you didn't quite realize how far the Lake District was from our house and you know that's just because you're not that good at geography that's not one of your special skills, Marianne. And, you know, just think about the jobs
然后突然又要四处奔波去参加不同的面试。我记得当时在伯明翰还有一个面试。有一天我突然想：“我做不到这一切了，这太沉重了。”我撞到了南墙，心想我在做什么。我几乎需要我妈妈的许可，让她说：“你为什么不取消湖区的面试呢？因为回想起来，你可能没意识到湖区离我们家有多远，而且那只是因为你不擅长地理，那不是你的特长，Marianne。”然后，想想那些
that will lead to less upheaval. And so, you know, when you're supporting your loved one and they're thinking about applying to jobs, you could help think with them about the real world impact of upping sticks and moving your entire life you know not to say don't do it but just to at the point where they're even applying for jobs think about whether they you know what factors would be involved and when they have still chosen to apply and maybe it hasn't worked out or they have had that moment like I had where I was just collapsed crying on the stairs you know just so out of resources what they might most need at that point is a hug not an I told you so because you know I know when I was speaking to my personal trainer we were talking about actually it's being really useful to have someone who can just listen.
会导致较少动荡的工作。所以，当你支持你的爱人，而他们正在考虑申请工作时，你可以和他们一起思考搬家对现实生活的影响。不是说不要去做，而是在他们申请工作时，思考一下会涉及哪些因素。当他们仍然选择申请，或者像我一样经历了崩溃，在楼梯上哭泣，资源耗尽时，他们最需要的可能是一个拥抱，而不是一句“我早就告诉过你了”。因为我知道，当我和我的私人教练交谈时，我们谈到，有一个能倾听的人真的很有用。
Not someone who tries to fix the problem, not someone who, you know, goes into problem solving mode. And I know that in our industry, in psychology, we can't really share details about our work. But we can bring up with you details about the themes that it evokes in us. And for me, yeah, like I said, it's, you know, as I as I reflect upon this now, I'm thinking about key images that you do sometimes get a bit stuck with. And I guess that's almost like a bit of vicarious trauma. And it's thinking about, you know, whether we might need some help processing some of those memories that get a bit stuck. So I'm not going to share mine with you. I don't want to vicariously traumatize you. But it's certainly useful to talk about this stuff with your supervisor or with someone that you love if it isn't breaking confidentiality because
不是那种试图解决问题的人，不是那种进入“解决问题模式”的人。我知道在我们的行业，在心理学领域，我们不能真正分享工作的细节。但我们可以和你谈论它在我们心中引发的主题。对我来说，正如我现在反思的那样，我想到了一些你有时会挥之不去的关键画面。我想那几乎就像一种替代性创伤。我们需要思考是否需要一些帮助来处理那些挥之不去的记忆。所以我不会和你分享我的，我不想让你产生替代性创伤。但如果这不违反保密原则，和你的督导或你爱的人谈论这些事情确实很有用，因为
what we know about trauma and what we know about things that do get stuck in our minds is that it makes us think like we shouldn't talk about them or think about them or we can't cope with thinking about them. But what we also know about treating trauma is that when we begin to be able to accept what's happened, to think about what's happened and to control what's happened. And if you do like the idea of acceptance and control, you could also try listening to the podcast episode with the lovely psychologist who wrote Act Made Yorkshire, which you can also download from all of your favourite podcast empires, I shall say so yeah ACT can be really transformational for clients but also for us as aspiring psychologists as well but what we know is when we're able to manipulate and explore and think about those things that the little tenterhooks that trauma has got into us are kind of
我们对创伤的了解，以及我们对那些挥之不去的想法的了解是，它们让我们觉得不应该谈论或思考它们，或者我们无法应对这些想法。但我们也知道，治疗创伤的方法是，当我们开始能够接受所发生的事情，思考所发生的事情，并控制所发生的事情时。如果你喜欢“接受与控制”这个概念，你也可以去听听那期播客，嘉宾是一位写了《ACT Made Yorkshire》的可爱心理学家，你也可以从你最喜欢的播客平台下载。所以，ACT对客户来说确实具有变革性，对我们这些有抱负的心理学家来说也是如此。但我们知道，当我们能够操纵、探索和思考那些事情时，创伤留给我们的那些小钩子就会被
freed up and if you can imagine I grew up with cats but you know they'd get those little burrs in their fur and you have to try and ease them out and then they're not bothering the cat anymore um so yeah trauma can be a little bit like that needs a little bit of help getting out of the fur that it's got stuck into okay let's pause here And you're getting a little exclusive of the first play of my own little jingle. You may have heard it already if you're already connected to me on LinkedIn. If you are on LinkedIn or if you're registered on LinkedIn, you can click on my face and this video will play to you. And I'm even like a little bit dancey in it as well. So who doesn't want to see that, right?
释放出来。如果你能想象一下，我从小养猫，它们毛里会粘上那些小刺，你必须试着把它们弄出来，然后它们就不会再困扰猫了。所以，创伤有点像那样，需要一点帮助才能从它粘住的毛发中解脱出来。好了，让我们在这里暂停一下。你正在听到我自己的小片头曲的独家首播。如果你已经在LinkedIn上与我建立了联系，你可能已经听过了。如果你在LinkedIn上，或者在LinkedIn上注册了，你可以点击我的头像，这段视频就会为你播放。我甚至在里面跳了一点舞。所以谁不想看这个呢，对吧？
But yeah, if you would like to watch some audio to go with this visual, you know what to do. Go to LinkedIn and click my face. You've got permission. Go on. is here to help aspiring psychologists she can help you become a success she has books podcasts and does a q a she's here to help in so many ways it's dr marianne Okay, so welcome back. If you are supporting someone that you love, that you care about very much as an aspiring psychologist, then sometimes we might need a little bit of help with just, you know, feeling like someone does care for us.
但如果你想观看与此视觉效果相匹配的音频，你知道该怎么做。去LinkedIn点击我的头像。你得到许可了，去吧。她在这里帮助有抱负的心理学家，她能帮你走向成功，她有书、播客，还做问答，她以多种方式提供帮助，她是Marianne博士。好了，欢迎回来。如果你正在支持一位你非常爱护的有抱负的心理学家，那么有时我们可能需要一点帮助，去感受有人确实关心我们。
I've often thought how weird it would be to date another carer, you know, to date a nurse or a doctor or, you know, an occupational therapist or another psychologist. Gosh, that would be weird for me. Someone that's also, you know, used to being in the care profession. You know, how would you ever get through a door if you're both, if you're both really, you know, selfless, caring people? You know, is it not like constantly oh no after you oh no no after you I insist um you know how does that get done so if you are in a relationship with someone else who also is in the caring profession do let me know what that's like for you because I've only ever really dated people in management and sales um I don't know what that's like for you because I've only ever really dated people in management and sales um
我经常想，和另一个护理人员约会会是多么奇怪，比如和护士、医生、职业治疗师或另一位心理学家约会。天哪，对我来说那太奇怪了。如果对方也习惯了从事护理行业。如果你们俩都是无私、有爱心的人，那你们怎么进门呢？是不是会一直说：“哦，不，你先请。”“哦，不，不，你先请，我坚持。”那会是什么样呢？所以，如果你正处于一段与同样从事护理行业的人的关系中，请一定要告诉我那是什么感觉，因为我只和从事管理和销售的人约会过。
I don't know what that's about you know could probably formulate that but that's just the kind of people that I've ended up with um and my husband definitely fits that camp as well so um yeah some but sometimes you know what we need is someone to know that we're, you know, the end of a tricky week or even a tricky day. And when we get in, you know, there's a bath run for us and, you know, there's a spaghetti bolognese underway. And then, you know, whilst we don't advocate drinking, if there happened to be a glass of wine on the table with dinner that might be ultra lovely you know and I think if you are studying whilst you're working or if you're striving generally it can be really useful if you've got a partner or even if you have just got um you know someone else that you care about that's in your life, to help make sure they know about any
我不知道那是什么感觉，可能可以构思一下，但这只是我最终选择的人的类型。我丈夫也绝对属于那一类。所以，有时我们需要的是有人知道我们度过了艰难的一周，甚至艰难的一天。当我们回家时，有人为我们放好了洗澡水，准备好了意大利肉酱面。然后，虽然我们不提倡饮酒，但如果晚餐时桌上有一杯红酒，那可能会非常美妙。我认为，如果你在工作的同时学习，或者如果你在努力奋斗，如果你的伴侣，或者哪怕只是你生命中关心的人，能确保他们知道任何
upcoming deadlines and submission dates. So when we are in academia, we usually will have submission dates given to us, like for the whole course, basically. I think I had the whole, the whole lot of submission dates for all of my essays, you know, almost like two years ahead of schedule, three years ahead of schedule. And so I could predict and plan, you know, leave in around those. And, you know, it's useful if someone else has also got that in mind as well. Because then, you know, if you do try to book, you know, some trip that's close to it, you know, it's just worth that conversation of, well, you know, but you have obviously got that essay in at that time. And similarly, you know, the period of September to springy summer can be tricky for
即将到来的截止日期和提交日期，那会非常有用。当我们身处学术界时，我们通常会提前得到提交日期，基本上是整个课程的。我想我几乎提前两年、三年就拿到了所有论文的提交日期。所以我可以预测并计划，围绕这些日期安排休假。如果别人也能考虑到这一点，那会很有用。因为这样，如果你试图预订一个临近的旅行，你们就可以讨论一下：“但你显然在那段时间有论文要交。”同样，从九月到春夏季这段时间对
aspiring psychologists because you don't know whether you might be called on for interview and someone in my membership was telling me recently that their partners found it very tricky, very tricky knowing how to support them during this application and interview season and so let's think about that as well. So just holding in mind those important dates, you know, for things happening. But also when people have got interviews, you know, it's quite normal at times to have like a crisis of confidence. So even on the day where I did my first ever private psychology appointment, I was just really highly strung. I was, you know, had all the imposter syndrome going on. I remember having a little sob at my kitchen sink because I just was so worried about it
有抱负的心理学家来说可能很棘手，因为你不知道自己是否会被叫去面试。我会员群里的一位成员最近告诉我，他们的伴侣在申请和面试季节期间不知道如何支持他们，觉得非常困难。所以我们也来思考一下这个问题。记住那些重要的日期，但当人们有面试时，有时出现“信心危机”是很正常的。即使在我进行第一次私人心理咨询的那天，我也非常紧张。我当时充满了冒名顶替综合症。我记得在厨房水槽边小哭了一场，因为我太担心
not working or someone thinking I wasn't good enough. And it's really normal that we feel worried about things when we haven't done them before. We can't expect ourselves to be an expert in something we haven't done before. And for me, the thing I hadn't done before was transact directly my time for money with a client because I'd always been paid by an employer before and this was this was brand new for me and that felt like all new kinds of levels of vulnerability and exposure and so you know what you wouldn't want to be doing in that circumstance is kind of invalidating that and saying you know you you do this all the time you know you've been qualified for years you know I don't get it you know because that's invalidating the way someone's feeling
它会失败，或者有人认为我不够好。当我们以前没做过某事时，感到担心是非常正常的。我们不能指望自己在没做过的事情上成为专家。对我来说，我以前没做过的事情就是直接用我的时间换取客户的钱，因为我以前总是由雇主支付工资，这对我来说是全新的。这感觉像是各种新的脆弱和暴露。所以，在这种情况下，你不想做的事情就是否定这种感觉，说：“你一直都在做这个，你已经有资格好几年了，我不明白。”因为那是在否定一个人的感受。
you know a more compassionate stance of what's really normal to feel like this, because this is a big deal, you know, this matters. So whether you could think about just shaping your, your language to be more, yeah, more compassionate and more on board with what your loved one is bringing to you. So they're not asking you to fix it. They're just asking you to kind of sit with them in their distress, really. So whether you could just take a breath, lower your own shoulders and just, you know, maybe give them a hug and say, you know, I think this is going to be OK. I think we've you know, you just got to be there, go out there, show them your brilliant self. And then I will be here for you at the tail end of the day and we can chat through how it went and we'll just see how that goes. So you're regularly running baths and
一种更具同情心的立场是：“感到这样是很正常的，因为这是一件大事，这很重要。”所以，你可以考虑调整你的语言，变得更具同情心，更支持你的爱人带给你的感受。他们不是要求你解决问题，他们只是要求你陪伴在他们的痛苦中。所以，你能不能深呼吸，放松自己的肩膀，给他们一个拥抱，说：“我觉得这会没事的。你只需要去那里，展示你出色的自己。然后我会在一天结束时在这里等你，我们可以聊聊进展如何，看看会发生什么。”所以，你经常放洗澡水，
making spaghetti bolognese, you are on call you know for when things feel wobbly, you're mindful of upcoming dates and important submission deadlines, you are like just fully available with hugs. All of that stuff I'd say it sounds like you're doing a grand job but sometimes you know this kind of work does take its toll so when we do start training, it's really common for a number of relationships in the cohort to break down and for people to kind of, I don't know, we never quite worked out whether it's a case of suddenly getting your ducks in a row that makes you look at other duck areas of your life and think whether that's working for you or whether it's the unique stresses and change that goes on throughout you know commuting or whether it's you know just that developing in this profession means that we do change and grow. And sometimes it means that we will grow in a different direction than people that we have been with previously. And things can make you can feel a little bit stagnant, maybe. And so maybe that's a reason why relationships
做意大利肉酱面，随时待命应对他们感到动摇的时候，留意即将到来的日期和重要的提交截止日期，你就像是一个完全提供拥抱的人。所有这些，我会说你做得非常棒。但有时这种工作确实会带来代价。当我们开始培训时，同伴中很多关系破裂是很常见的。人们会……我不知道，我们从来没弄清楚这是否是因为突然理清了思绪，让你审视生活中其他领域是否适合你，还是因为在通勤过程中经历的独特压力和变化，或者仅仅是因为在这个职业中的发展意味着我们确实在改变和成长。有时这意味着我们会朝着与以前在一起的人不同的方向成长。事情会让你感到有点停滞。所以也许这就是关系
break down. But if you're listening to this because you are with someone who is an aspiring psychologist, then it's perhaps useful for you to know that figure, that stat. I don't know if there has been research done into it, but it is super common. So, you know, if you're looking for a thesis topic, anybody, that might be one to look into because certainly within my cohort alone, there was a number of breakups and there was in the year below and the year above, there always is, you know, and it's because it's life, isn't it? Life happens. But yeah, it's worth bearing that in mind. Because if you don't want to be without this person that you're listening to this podcast about, then you're
破裂的原因。但如果你正在听这期节目，因为你正与一位有抱负的心理学家在一起，那么了解这个数据可能对你有用。我不知道是否有人对此做过研究，但这非常普遍。所以，如果你正在寻找论文题目，这可能是一个值得研究的方向。因为仅在我那一届，就有好几对分手了，下面一届和上面一届也是如此，总是这样。这就是生活，不是吗？生活总会发生。但这是值得记住的。因为如果你不想失去这个你正在听播客谈论的人，那么你
going to need to make sure that you are on the same team, you know, that you are talking regularly, that you are, you know, on board with their goals as well. And maybe even thinking about growing with them or growing in some other areas so that you're also energized but when we start placements when we start new job roles when we're doing anything new for that matter we can become a little bit like our very much younger selves so when when babies are learning to do new things their sleep can go haywire because they're processing and they're laying down all these new neural pathways um they call them developmental leaps um in in in psychology um child development terms um suddenly the sleep gets even more bonkers and you're like i didn't
需要确保你们在同一个团队，你们在定期沟通，你们也支持他们的目标。甚至考虑与他们一起成长，或者在其他领域成长，这样你们也能充满活力。但当我们开始实习、开始新的工作角色，或者做任何新的事情时，我们可能会变得有点像我们小时候。当婴儿学习做新事情时，他们的睡眠会变得一团糟，因为他们正在处理并建立所有这些新的神经通路。在心理学和儿童发展术语中，他们称之为“发展飞跃”。突然间，睡眠变得更加疯狂，你会想：“我没
think it was possible to be any worse than it was. I was wrong. I was naive. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. And I think the same is true of new placements and new jobs and new theories that we're learning. Our sleep can go equally bonkers, you know,
想到它会比以前更糟。我错了，我太天真了。我很抱歉。”我认为新的实习、新的工作和我们正在学习的新理论也是如此。我们的睡眠也会变得同样疯狂。
and it's just knowing that that will pass knowing that the person that you love or if you're listening to us because it's you you're the person you love um you know just expecting and um knowing that that will settle down it's just really normal um that we that we have that way of processing know, that our sleep can go a bit bonkers. So this time will pass. But yeah, knowing that it can be really stressful. So even within most doctoral courses where there's placements, there will be at least six placements across a three-year period.
只要知道这会过去，知道你爱的人，或者如果你是因为自己而听这期节目，那么你就是你爱的人……只要期待并知道这会平息下来，这真的很正常。我们有那种处理方式，我们的睡眠会变得有点疯狂。所以这段时间会过去。但要知道这可能压力很大。所以即使在大多数博士课程中，三年内至少会有六次实习。
That's a lot of change it's a lot of new people to learn you know faces and names and different systems and some of these you know placements might use different operating systems it's a lot to learn there's really a great many steep learning curves and so it's just knowing what your loved one is going to be going through as they you know embark upon then these next stages of their career it isn't a case of getting you know that doctoral offer or whatever and then it's plain sailing it is tricky you know there's a lot of hoops to jump through and knowing that if a placement isn't going so well that that is going to really impact on that person and they might need you all the more with your arms and your spaghetti
这有很多变化，有很多新面孔、新名字和不同的系统需要学习。其中一些实习可能使用不同的操作系统，有很多东西要学，有很多陡峭的学习曲线。所以，只要知道你的爱人在开启职业生涯的下一阶段时会经历什么。这并不是说拿到博士录取通知书就万事大吉了，这很棘手，有很多障碍要跨越。要知道，如果实习进行得不顺利，那会对那个人产生很大的影响，他们可能更需要你的怀抱和意大利肉酱面。
bolognese so I hope that you found this a really helpful thought-provoking compassionate episode as ever I would welcome any thoughts that you've got around any of this and if you've got any special requests for podcast episodes please do get in contact with me you can do that with the details in the show notes section or on my link tree which is dr mar Marianne Trent on Linktree. Any other points that I would like to talk to you about? Let me have a little think about that. Yes, if you do like what I talk about and the kind of things I help you with, then you might find it helpful to sign up to my aspiring psychologist membership waiting list which opens again on the 1st of July 2022 you can come and come and get involved and when that opens I will let you know and you can come and book on but it's a really nice membership
所以我希望你觉得这是一期非常有帮助、发人深省且充满同情心的节目。一如既往，欢迎你对这一切提出任何想法。如果你对播客节目有任何特殊要求，请务必与我联系。你可以通过节目说明部分的详细信息或我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent）与我联系。还有什么我想和你谈谈的吗？让我思考一下。是的，如果你喜欢我谈论的内容以及我帮助你的方式，那么你可能会觉得注册我的“有抱负的心理学家会员”候补名单很有用，该名单将于2022年7月1日再次开放。你可以加入进来，当它开放时，我会通知你，你可以预订。这是一个非常好的会员
group people are finding it very supportive and you you know, helpful, energizing, all of that stuff. So if that sounds like something that might be useful for you, then do come along to that. I'm also going to be setting up a free Facebook group, which is as yet untitled. So watch this space. I think that might be about it for now. But yeah, do come and connect with me on socials. I love helping you celebrate. And if you've got any thoughts about this episode,
群体，人们觉得它非常有支持力，很有帮助，充满活力。所以如果这听起来对你有用，那就加入吧。我还将建立一个免费的Facebook群组，目前还没有命名。所以敬请期待。我想现在就这些了。但一定要在社交媒体上与我联系。我喜欢帮助你们庆祝。如果你对这期节目有任何想法，
or if you'd like to record a testimonial for me to appear within the podcast about any of my work and content, then do please get in contact. Otherwise, thank you for listening and be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with Dr Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are
或者如果你想录制一段推荐语，让我出现在播客中谈论我的任何工作和内容，请务必与我联系。否则，感谢你的收听，祝你在成为合格心理学家的道路上一切顺利。这是Marianne Trent博士的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫Jana，是一名实习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。这让我惊讶于有这么多不同的途径
to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me, you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
可以达到目标，成为一名心理学家没有完美的途径。这让我充满了信心，觉得我没有做错，也减轻了自己的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来了。这期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。